the watch list also known as the
terrorist screening database is used by
US intelligence agencies to nominate
people as known or suspected terrorists
over the past 15 years the list has
grown from a few thousand to more than 1
million names but the most troubling
fact is that leaked documents revealed
that forty percent of the names on the
list had no established ties to
recognize terrorist organizations so why
are these people on the list
[Music]
mehar are is a syrian-born Canadian
citizen he was stopped at JFK Airport in
New York when returning from a family
vacation in Tunisia in 2002 I was
traveling back from Tunis to Montreal I
had to transfer the FK I was integrated
by the FBI for long hours I was
eventually taken to the Metropolitan
Detention Center and accused of being a
member of al-qaeda they refused to show
me any evidence of that and I kept
asking for a lawyer to make a phone call
they would never allow me to do that and
then all of a sudden in the middle of
the night they came in and took me to
private jet and they shipped me off to
Jordan like a parcel the US government
sent Ma her to Jordan where he was then
transported under duress to his
birthplace of Syria and imprisoned for
ten agonizing months separated from his
wife and children maha was tortured
beaten and kept in a 3 by 6 foot jail
cell I call it the coffin now if it's
that that white exactly that white and
about 60 feet deep and about seven feet
high it's an underground completely dark
there was just a little bit of opening
and the top I'll be honest with you that
cell was more mental torture than the
physical torture and I don't know how
survived that it was awful i had the
breakdowns in that place i I think I
thought I was gonna die I thought I was
just that's it for me I always say when
I talk about your case my hair our was
kidnapped he has JFK Airport yes i was i
was literally kidnapped by state agents
I think they just used the the law to go
around the law that's what it is a
Canadian investigation determined ma her
was completely innocent and that the
mistake was based on faulty intelligence
in this country i think we think of
ourselves as this incredibly free
society but i think few americans are
aware of the fact that there's a secret
justice system where you're not allowed
to know the rules you're not even
allowed to know why you've been put on a
terror watch list